croo Lucifer that's lucer with an L is
one of the most enigmatic existences in
all of the animes and the mangas with
occupation titles such as thief thief
boss boss of Thieves floor master of
Heaven's Arena and even known by some as
the red cleaner which conjures up all
sorts of gory unwell images but is
actually a reference to C's canonical
voice act in Korea which started at a
young age then took a rather Bleak T and
then whoops he committed a genocide crlo
is a complicated character to say the
least like complicated in contrast we
often call characters like hisoka
complex but compared to CR he is
boringly simple Hoka can be summed up as
horny clown wants to come whereas crlo
can't be summarized the interesting
thing about Hoka is that we know what he
is but we don't quite understand what
made him that way his history is
mysterious but CR is very much the
opposite we know his history quite
extensively and yet it really doesn't
bring us much closer to actually
understanding him but let's give it a go
Prolo is from meteor City and despite
its reputation crlo actually had a
fairly happy childhood up until a
certain very unhappy corpsey traumatic
friend killing point but you know we'll
get to that as a child to entertain
himself he used to play in garbage with
other future troop members and one of
their Hobbies was Finding discarded
videotapes to watch in the city's
dedicated AV room and you never really
knew what you were going to get here but
crawler watched every tape including up
to 20 volumes of a series called
learning Gelman a foreign language
course and so C actually found enough of
these tapes to become fluent in Gilman
very handy because he would go on to
find another extensive series of tapes
in Gilman known as The Mighty sweep in
Power Cleaners and because K spoke
fluent Gelman now he decided to
translate the tape and have he and his
friends dubb the voices of the
characters at live screenings in the
most innocent way possible this was the
formation of what would go on to become
known as the Phantom troop with many of
the troops founding members given dub
rolls including FX noaga pakunoda sarasa
and fatan who's sarasa you ask well you
going to regret asking that question
also this fictional Hunter content is
sponsored by Dungeon Hunter 6 the
stunning fantasy unique hero collector
arpg with fastpaced hack and/ combat to
utilize against bosses like really big
bosses it's absolutely free to play you
can download it now using the link in
the description or you can scan the QR
code on screen if you're viewing it on
PC and here's why you should because in
this game killing bosses is not the end
no no no that's just the prologue to the
story because you can then summon your
conquered Bowes to become your squad
members make them follow you perform
Perfect combo skills and even shape
shift into them to harness the ultimate
of powers speaking of there's a lot of
Creative Design in this game like the
customizable Mount system allowing you
to ride a whole ton of fantasy creatures
and all sorts of wacky Machinery plus
Dungeon Hunter 6 takes Graphics to a
whole new level with the most stunning
and smoothest of animations on mobile
devices with a wide array of other
features such as playing with guildmates
a variety of skill tree options and
trading via the auction system you can
download the game for free on Android or
iOS using my link in the description or
scan the QR code on screen if you're
viewing it on on a PC to get a free
special start a pack worth $50 e dues
including 10 summoning Scrolls one SSR
Lieutenant demonic wolf and an accessory
pack plus you can use your game account
to enter the launch Lucky Spin event for
free with great prizes such as the
iPhone 15 Pro Max PlayStation 5S Apple
watches and even more starting on
October 15th so let's all thank Dungeon
Hunter for sponsoring our addiction to
fictional Hunter content but for now
it's back to you me sarasa was a girl
who loved performing with her friends so
much that she invested extra time into
finding new tech all by herself and one
day she was abducted tortured and
ultimately murdered in a forest the
whole Affair having been filmed and what
remained of her body being hung up for
her friends to find a note was left with
her remains which was written in Gilman
however its contents were so scarring
that crlo vowed never to translate it
even going so far as to say I'll never
speak of it even if you try to kill me
and From This Moment On crlo changed he
became so consumed with finding sasa's
killers that he developed a three-year
plan to morph what good goodness remain
of meteor City into a paradise for the
worst Humanity has to offer the general
idea was to create a bit of a safe space
for criminals to screen their art hoping
that one day sarasa Killers would come
and screen their film basically he
wanted to build a Sundance for snuff
films and the rest of the children
agreed to Carlo's plan with one
exception being Sheila she's a very
intriguing character as well but one for
a very different video but feeling the
same desire for vengeance these meteor
City kidlets elected crlo as their
leader and this was the informal found
of the Phantom Troop C then disappeared
for 3 years to piece his plan together
and when he returned to medeor City at
the age of 14 he officially formed the
Fantom troop based on the structure of a
spider C described the organization as
follows I'm the head and you're the legs
the legs do what the head says there
will be times when the legs are more
important than the head if I die someone
else will take over my orders are of the
utmost priority my life is not be sure
to make the right decision I am only a
part of the spider what's important is
the survival of the whole not the
individual to which everyone else
replied oh hi CR nice to see you too
what's it been you know 3 years all
right yeah let's let's do you spyer
thing I am of course being a bit
flipping to you but that is more or less
how it happened crawler returned to
medor city and before he even said hi he
just started preaching with everyone
else just going wait is that CR and
should I be listening to what he's
saying but listen they did and to
solidify this group each member was
given a spider tattoo with an
accompanying number but crlo you see he
was a very special boy and he was given
the number zero it's also unknown where
crawler's tattoo is or if indeed he
actually has one you'll sometimes hear
it said on the internet that crawler's
tattoo was on his arm and there is
reason for this as the 1999 anime is
responsible because they made the
decision to show the spider tattoo on
his right arm weirdly enough though they
chose not to include the number but in
the manga he has no such tattoo on his
arm to be fair maybe it was on his left
arm D know can't really see it because
it got blown the F off the most recent
entry is the 2011 anime and they wanted
nothing to do with this they said we
don't care to weigh in on this
controversy by censoring the blown-off
arm and even keeping both arms rather
conservatively covered neither
confirming nor denying anything when it
comes to crlo he's one of the more
inconsistent characters across the three
different Hunter Hunters really the only
thing that all three series can agree on
is that his hair is black which is more
than you can say for Hoka in the 1999
anime his hair is blue 2011 is Scarlet
and in the manga it's bright orange
whatever the case K's plan worked meor
City on went something of a dark
Renaissance and became a hot spot for
many of the world's sickest Minds
there's no way to tell how many snuff
films CR watched tens hundreds maybe
thousands and to this day we don't
actually know if the troop found sasa's
tape or her Killers for that matter it's
likely they did because the focus of the
troop these days has nothing to do with
Sasa or the how shall we say film
industry as a whole there probably a
better way to say that what's like a
like a really dark term for Hollywood
like a Hollywood but it's run by
horrible people people actually you know
what Hollywood still works however after
the lengths that CR went to in order to
take revenge he arguably became just as
bad if not worse than sasa's Killers
which is very much epitomized through
the most notable troop action in the
series being the CTA Massacre where the
Fantom troop reportedly tortured the
children of the clan before gouging out
their scared eyes to ensure the most
vibrant of Reds which would sell for the
highest of prices I'd say at least they
didn't film it but we don't know that
I'm sure those particular movie films
would have sold for quite a bit in this
world but with that and also other non-
genocide based actions crlo and the
Phantom troop became Infamous worldwide
criminals with class A bounties the
highest available although their Bounty
amounts have never been disclosed which
has caused fans to turnone to giving
them terribly calculated onepiece
bounties but CR was able to do all of
this because of his exceptional n
abilities which was interesting because
it's unknown exactly when and how crlo
learned nen the first confirmed nen user
in the Phantom troop is Machi who was
able to see the aura of r o and this may
have been a Gateway for all of the trets
however KOLO may have also learned this
elsewhere during his 3 years away
whatever the case KOLO is a specialist
whose heartu reflects his spider
philosophy there is one head and many
legs his ability skill Hunter is
designed to acquire the legs of others
and by legs I mean the N abilities many
many legs all used by one head and so CR
is actually the owner of the most n
abilities in the series to date
including his two original hotu skill
Hunter and double face C has used 11
hotu when hunt Hunter and almost
certainly has access to far more he's a
bit of a nen multi-tool and best known
in Hunter Hunter for his intellect
because CR always uses these abilities
in the most perfect and precise manner
so perhaps unsurprisingly in terms of
physical strength CR is actually quite
lacking compared to the rest of the
troop CR ranks in seventh place in the R
wrestling contests meaning that his
strength is even outclassed by Machi who
sits in sixth place this doesn't mean
that croo is physically Weak by any
means though he is still a worldclass
fight battling man so much so that
historic Al he is one of the few people
to fight a fully-fledged zelic assassin
and live prior to the beginning of
Hunter Hunter Prolo had an altercation
with one silver zalic where both of them
managed to survive that that right there
is already a miracle for most people who
engage with a zalic assassin it is the
very last choice they ever make but mate
this this C guy he then had the balls to
fight two zelics at the same time during
York New City Bood Zeno and Silva zalic
were hired by the 10 Dons to kill croo
and on this second occasion he almost
certainly would have been killed if not
for a bout of cleverness you see crlo
being very good at brain thinking hired
his own set of zics to kill the 10 Don
and when they died the contract on his
head expired all crawler had to do was
survive long enough for a contract to be
terminated which he did but why did he
do what he did and why would he go on to
do what he does even with kolo's power
and intelligence his motives are still
pretty unclear C himself even admits
this in chapter 111 I don't like to talk
about my motives which that's fair
enough I guess I will say that most of
his plans revolve around acquiring rare
items for the troop to sell for some
sweet sweet cash money but What Becomes
of said sweet cash monies are a mystery
a lot of it may get sent back to medeor
City because the troop do protect it or
perhaps it's all funding for a much
larger project or maybe crlo needs to
keep making money in order to save
himself from being brutally kill
murdered by zics the average going rate
for a zalic assassination is a billion
Jenny ahead so C had to Fork over at
least 10 billion Jenny just to keep
himself alive during York but also maybe
it's not about the money at all not
counting the curta clan which which is a
big thing to discount but just go with
me for a second not counting them crlo
operates mostly within the underworld
his two major targets in Hunter Hunter
thus far have been the 10 Don of York
New City and the Ken Empire both of whom
are wildly corrupt entities that indulge
in the height of human atrocity for
example na nrad a mafia boss's daughter
was also a body par collector and her
father lighton strad also had an
appreciation for the Arts he even made
his own art that one time when he killed
framed and hung one of his own
bodyguards on the wall meanwhile fourth
Prince Rik is a renowned appreciator of
sickening art and this disregard for
human life for the sake of art
Collectibles or entertainment is exactly
the attitude that led to sasa's murder
so it would make sense that kler would
Target these entities especially when if
all you wanted to do was make money
there are far easier targets like say
beta that dude was a multi-billionaire
rich enough to buy almost every copy of
Greed Island with pretty pathetic
security as well he would be such an
easy Mark for the troop to Rob or
blackmail but then again all the guy
wanted to do was find a cure for the
love of his life he wasn't interested in
the darker doors that wealth can open
and so the Phantom troop w't interested
in him Kos hardly a Punisher there even
forgetting about the Kur to Clan which
again another big thing to forget about
but even doing that PR's action still
end up killing a lot of arguable
innocent people even prompting gone to
ask how can you kill people who have
nothing to do with you and in response
to this firstly C is drawn with a rare
burst of emotion C is almost always
portrayed with a neutral expression even
in the midst of battle but here what gon
said struck a nerve a big sarasa shaped
nerve in this moment what croo sees is
his younger self confronting sasa's
Killers asking them how could you do
this to someone who has nothing to do
with you and now all of these years down
the line crawl is on the other side and
what's worse is that he may now
legitimately be able to empathize with
sasa's Killers cr's chilling reply to
gone is I don't know it might be because
they have nothing to do with me so at
this point in his life KOLO seems to
have abandoned forging new connections
everyone he actually cares about is a
childhood friend he's even cold and
distant and newer members of the Phantom
troop characters like shizuku and
bonolenov who joined at later dates and
personally I don't think crlo was quite
sure of the answer to that question
himself he has a a lot of trouble
explaining his actions to gone and yeah
CR is one of the most intelligent people
in the world but that doesn't mean he
always has some sort of grand plan not
everything is a game of 12d spider chest
and crlo himself could very much just be
lost his motivation was to bring Justice
to sas's murder but in that Quest he has
now committed countless sasas so where
do you even go from there or how do you
justify your own actions C's solution to
this appears to become so disconnected
from Humanity that he's not even sure
why he does anything for example Le in
his fight against isoka Klo says one of
the more interesting lines which is
humans are so very interesting he says
this in response to hisoka being so
determined to fight him despite that
from K's perspective his victory was
100% guaranteed despite that hisoka
still wanted to do it so there's this
distinct separation like croo is now an
alien observing the human race and Hoka
is a great foil for C because they're
such opposites Prolo feels nothing when
killing whereas Hoka kills in order to
feel and the closer he is to death the
more intense the feeling these are two
figures who could never understand each
other or could they because after
Reviving isoka made it his mission to
kill each and every member of the
Phantom troop and with each murdered
member isoka is gradually severing all
of cr's remaining connections to
humanity but also at the same time
inspiring crlo to want to kill someone
to feel for the first time since Sasa
but just how many more troop members is
this going to cost and ultimately what
will K's life have accomplished